大家好,很高興能接受盈餘社區的邀請,在這裡給大家分享我們的一些相關工作,介紹數連網的相關知識。
我是北京大學數據空間技術與系統全國重點實驗室的羅超然。
今天給大家帶來的題目是數連網與數據空間,私語數據寡遇流通及可信服用的技術設施。
今天的報告分為三個部分,首先是數字經濟的發展,面臨的高質量的數據危機。
第二部分是數據危機的破解指導,私語數據的廣域服用。
第三部分是我們數據空間全國重點實驗室在數連網和數據空間方面的實驗與展望。
首先,我們之所以能夠大家在這裡學習數連網、數據記錄設施的相關知識。
其實從根本上來講,是因為我們國家在2020年的時候,國務院發表了加快完善社會主義市場經濟體制第一顛東提出了要加快培育發展數據要素市場,
把數據作為繼土地勞動力、資本科技之後的第五大生產要素,並基於數據要素來去推動數字經濟的高質量發展。
在那之後,我們國家出台了一系列的政策文件,並且成立了國家數據局來推動這個事的落實。
所以說,數據要素和數據記錄設施是當前國家重要的戰略。
不僅要問一下,數據這個東西好像自古以來就有。
從早期上古時期,我們用結石來去記錄事件開始,
包括我們用文字寫、用竹剪寫,其實本質上都是數據。
數據其實核心它是對現實世界信息的記錄,長期以來一直存在。
那為什麼到2020年的時候,國家提出要把數據作為一個數據要素,這背後的原理到底是什麼呢?
其實我們從人類科學發展史的角度可以給這個問題一個視角的答案。
竹林獎的得主吉姆格雷,他在2008年的時候提出了人類科學發展的四個階段。
第一個階段是觀察實驗,通過觀察到一個現象,並且通過實驗來去重複這個事情,
驗證這個現象的可重複性,從而得到一個科學的理論。
那典型的代表就是戈返尼的日新說,還有加利略的兩個小球同時落地。
第二階段是理論推演,通過數學工具來去在已經被證明的一些結論之上,
通過數學的推導的方式來去得到一個新的科學的原理,這個就是理論推演方式。
典型的代表就是萬有盈利定律,實際上它理論的誕生是要先於實驗的發現的。
那第三方式就是計算模擬方式,有一些現實世界顯而易見,
但是通過數學難以證明的一些典型的現象,比如說詞色定理。
但是我們通過計算機的方式來去把一些促使的參數輸到計算機裡面,通過計算機去模擬。
基本上現在可以做到模擬到幾百萬億個四塊,都符合詞色定理。
那我們就可以認為詞色定理它是成立的,這個就是計算模擬方式。
還有就是我們之前看過一個二戰時期的電影,就是《美麗心靈》,講的是圖靈嘛。
一大堆科學家,一大堆數學家在用數學去破解盟軍的密碼,
然後圖靈通過建了一個計算機來去把盟軍的,把德軍的這個密碼給破譯了。
其實本質上就是計算模擬方式對理論推演方式的一個顛覆。
那計算模擬方式在產業界,它的代表的各類的應用,其實就是信息化應用。
我們可以想一想,我們的這個數字政府,數字醫療,還有我們通過網站上去看一些網課等等一系列的行為,
其實本質上都是通過計算機來去對我們現實世界當中的實體,關係,還有業務流程進行了建模,
通過計算機的方式,通過光影號全地的方式,極大地去加速了這個業務流程的孕暖速度。
所以說我們才能可以在這麼方便的在手機上,就可以把號尾掛了,
可能在通過互聯網醫院就可以把病給看了,這個就是信息化應用。
第三方式在產業界的一個典型的代表,在信息化的過程當中產生了大量的數據資源,
包括我們單純利用這些數據資源。
如果對這些數據資源的官民性分析,我們就能得到一個新的科學原理,這個就是第四方式,數據探索的方式。
一個最典型的代表就是谷歌的流感預測系統,叫做Google Flow GFT,
它通過對用戶搜索瀏覽器,搜索信息,通過搜索引擎搜索信息的一些記錄,來去推導出來,
哪個地方可能會有流感爆發的風險,比如說我說的發燒、核瘦等等一些類的症狀。
在同一個地方集中多了,我就會預測這個地方可能會有流感發生。
而這個就是第四方式,而第四方式在產業界的代表就是我們所說的智能化應用。
而人工智能是第四方式是數據產生價值的重要手段,可以說是最主要的一個手段,
而這個也正式成為數據能夠成為生產要素的一個核心的技術進步。
那人工智能的發展其實大家應該都比較熟悉,就經歷過三波浪潮,
現在我們所說的人工智能更多的是深圖學習,
深圖學習可以通過大量的數據對深圖學習的神經網路進行訓練,
能夠讓它產生我們所謂的智能。這個智能可以幫助我們人類在現實世界當中進行分析,進行決策。
這個就是數據之所以能夠成為生產要素的核心的一個原理。
2022年現在的GPT誕生了,深圖學習對數據的消耗量大,
但是GPT為代表的大模型的誕生極大增加了人工智能對數據的消耗。
因為GPT採用了Transformer架構,這種架構下它可以把模型的參數量進行幾乎無限制的擴張。
那更大的參數量就意味著更大的順利、需求以及更大的數據需求,
所以說大模型可以說是現在的一個數據和順利的吞金獸,
它對數據的需求量基本上是會隨著參數量的增加而進行增加。
我們從一個政治定義學的視角來看數據、人工智能和數據的設施,
其實數據是生產要素,人工智能是生產力,而數據技術設施就是生產關係,
我們數據技術設施要構建適應人工智能的數據流通利用關係,
從而來去促進人工智能這個生產力的發展及數據要素的戰爭釋放。
1993年美國啟動了國家信息技術設施計劃,
在這個計劃裡面它提出了一些暢想,就是我們在美國預計在今後10到20年內
全面完成比如說兩個企業之間通過計算機進行細心交流,
然後在西海岸的老師可以在東海岸學生上課,
這個其實就可以看到是本身是信息化應用而構建的一個技術設施,
信息技術設施計劃它促進美國建設了我們所謂的信息高速公路,
它奠定了美國互聯網時代的霸主地位,
但是隨著這個人工智能技術的發展特別是大模型的出現,
大模型的發展需要指數級增長的數據量,
而當前我們通過信息技術設施也就是外威網所獲取的這個公寓數據,
它其實只能在以每年4%到5%的數據增長,
那生產力的發展導致舊的生產關係,也就是信息技術設施不再適應生產力水平,
需要構建新生產力水平的符合生產力水平的新生產關係,
也就是我們所說的數據技術設施,
接下來是第二部分,就是,
那大模型的發展給數據經濟的帶來了高質量的數據危機,
那我們通過什麼樣的方式來去解決這個數據危機呢,
其實就是私域數據的廣域服用,並不是說所有的數據都是在於信息力的數據增加的,
互聯網上的私域數據它一直都是在於指數級的數據增加,
只是公開和訪問的那一部分公域數據增長數據非常好慢,
而萬威網過去20餘年積累的海洋公域數據支援,
它確實是支撐了我們人工整整的廢數發展,
現在我們大模型的訓練其實大部分都是基於公域數據的語料來去訓練出來的,來去進行訓練的,
但是到2027年,萬威網上的所有公域高質量數據將消耗殆盡,
那怎麼去解,我們利用互聯網上不可公開訪問的這些私域數據,
實現私域數據的廣域服用,就成為了解決數據危機的及時,
那什麼是私域數據?舉個例子,
就在這個圖裡面大家仔細看可以看到,
就是我們在我們同樣一個問題問DeepSake,
然後什麼是數量網,然後在沒有連接到任何外部知識庫的情況下,
DeepSake回答的數量網基本上和我們現在所定義的數量網是相去甚遠的,
基本的英文翻譯都翻譯錯了,
那第二步我們打開它和萬威網的連接,
然後通過外威網的公域數據來去分析回答什麼是數量網,
它的回答看似靠譜了一些,
但是最基礎的數量網的翻譯仍然還是回答錯了,
那第三步我們把我們撰寫的數量網相關的文章,
當然還沒有公開發表的,還能證實私域數據的狀態,
然後為給大模型,然後讓大模型去回答同樣的問題,
它的回答基本上和我們預期是一致的,
同樣的英文翻譯,internet of data也是成全的,
所以說這個地方我們可以認為算法決定了智能的內涵,
順利決定了智能的下限,而數據決定了智能的上限,
所以說目前大模型的發展,
極需要私域數據的廣域服用來去度過大模型的能力,
那我們解決這個問題的方法就是使用數量網和數據空間,
那什麼是數量網和數據空間呢?
可以類比一下,就是數量網,
首先給他們一個清晰的定義,
數量網是互聯網上的虛擬數據網絡,
而數據空間是數量網上基於自然世界共識規則所形成的
數據實體活動及關係的集合,
很多朋友就是一聽數量網帶一個網字,
就可能會認為數量網是網絡層的東西,
比如說高速數據網之類的網絡數據傳輸的網絡,
但實際上數據網是在這些網絡之上,
所構成的虛擬的數據網絡,
它的核心的目標是把數據和從業務系統當中
成為一個獨立的實體,
能夠在互聯網上被標識、被定位、被發現和調度,
就可以類比為我們的萬維網,
萬維網網頁和網頁之間通過超連接形成的那個虛擬的網絡,
我們稱之為是web,
其實它就是一種文檔和文檔之間的互聯網,
而在這個文檔互聯網之上,
所構造的信息空間就類似於我們百度的服務器,
淘寶的服務器,還有這個騰訊的服務器,
然後在這個服務器之上,
每個服務器的內部它都有一個清晰的邊界,
這裡面分別是BAT3加不同的數據,
而基於這些數據就會有更多的信息應用,
比如說天貓、百度、淘寶等等。
同樣的,數據網這一塊也是這個邏輯,
只是一個是公域數據和一個是私域數據,
數據網把私域數據向互聯接形成一個網絡,
在數據空間在這之上,
基於不同的規則,
然後框住不同的數據實體,
在裡面進行數據的價值釋放,
從而支撐各類的信息應用,
例如數據模型、智慧城市、智能體等等。
可以類比為數據網它是微信,
而數據空間它是微信上構建的一個群,
群裡面有不同的成員,
不同成員可以在這裡面按照群裡面的規則,
來去共享相應的數據資源,
進行聊天。
接下來進一步舉個例子,
給大家再一次去描述一下數據網的內涵。
其實數據網它本身就已經存在,
就比如說我們以歷史範圍的科研為例,
谷歌它在2019年的時候,
發表了一篇論文叫《Bert》,
這個《Bert》用了一些數據集,
用了算法,
同年的7月,
百度發表了一篇文章,
叫《而你》,
同樣是用了《Bert》論文當中的相關數據集,
然後修改了《Bert》的一些原碼,
使它能夠去支撐中文,
同時加上了百度它所自由的一些中文的數據集,
就訓練出來一個《而你》的模型,
同時也發表了一篇論文。
於是同時臉書,也就是Facebook,
它基於它自由的一些社交網絡的數據,
然後修改了一部分原碼,
同樣再去進行訓練,
又形成了一個新的數據集叫做《Roberta》,
然後把信提升了很多,
然後又發表了一篇新的論文。
在這個過程當中,
數據和數據之間,
附用所形成的這個網絡,
就是數學網,
但是目前的這個數學網,
它邏輯上存在,事實上也存在,
但是缺乏有效的表證,構造和運行機制,
這就是嚴重制約的數據附用的效率和規模。
而數據空間呢,
就可以看到就是谷歌,
這個數據空間就可以明顯地分為三個,
一個是谷歌的數據空間,
一個是百度的數據空間,
一個是臉書的數據空間,
它們之間的數據都是存在,
都是存在邊界的,不可。
你在谷歌的數據空間裏面,
要遵循谷歌的數據使用的規則,
在百度的空間裏面要有百度的規則,
在臉書的空間裏面要有規則。
這個就是三個數據空間,
數據網的代表性工作,
首先呢,就是羅伯特卡恩他提出的數據對象架構,
其實就是我們剛剛看到的那個,
和論文之間的那個網絡,
羅伯特卡恩呢,
他基於他在這個,
這個資助管的工作的一個基礎上,
提出了在2006年的時候,
提出了數據對象架構,
他提出要把這個數據,
建模成標識原數據和實體,
三要數組成的數據項,
通過標識和標識之間的引用,
來去構建數據和數據之間的網絡,
就是數據網。
目前呢,最大的典型的應用,
就是我們的DIY系統,
DIY系統它,
應用範圍已經覆蓋全球啊,
我們每個發表的論文,
它都會被分配一個DIY號,
然後通過DIY號,
我們可以去構造,
論文和論文之間的引文網絡。
那第二個典型的應用呢,
就是鏈接數據架構,
Tim Berners-Lee,
他在98年提出,
萬維網的時候,
其實,
他的核心目標,
是要去實現人與人之間的信息共享,
所以說,
他的核心技術是HTML,
裡面更多的是,
描述的是,
怎麼從人可看到的視覺的角度,
來去組織信息,
還有HTDP,
傳述的是人可理解的文本。
那在2010年前後,
他也意識到,
就是機器,
可能未來是數據的
主要的產生方,
提供方和消費方。
所以說,
他提出了link的data這樣的架構,
來去把萬維網所構建的
文檔的網絡,
演化成數據
和數據之間的網絡,
也就是我們
基於予以往的相關技術,
來去構造這樣的一個網絡。
那目前,
可以看到,這個圖,
其實就是目前他說,
予以往落的一個規模。
我們全國重點實驗室,
也是一直沿著數據網和數據空間的方向,
來去進行,
系統性的開展,
高水平的應用技術研究,
前線技術探索和觀點技術公關。
我們是
2020年的時候,
中央批付由北京大學,
海添區政府等四方
空間一個新型研發機構,
並且這個研發機構在
2023年,
獲批了數據領域唯一的
全國重點實驗室。
圍繞的數據網,
做數據空間兩大
核心技術和難題,
來去進行技術公關。
我們目前也是
牽頭編寫了數據網和
核心數據空間的國家標準。
這兩個標準,
按照我們
前述,
假述的數據網和數據空間之間的關係,
也非常的清晰。
數據網和核心解決數據
順利網絡資源的調度問題,
而
核心數據空間呢,
這解決主體規則
他們之間如何形成共識的問題。
也就是說
通過數據網,
你可以找到這個數據,
你可以在不考慮
受權不考慮,
核心不考慮安全的情況下,
找到這個數據,
並且
能夠
把數據調度到你所需要的
節點,或者說你所需要
對它進行處理的順利解決看。
而核心數據空間呢,
則核心關注於
誰能夠加入這個空間,
誰能夠在這個空間裡面
共享數據,
共享數據的規則是什麼?
共享數據的相關數據,
參與方,它需要形成
規則上面的共識,這個是核心數據空間的
關注的核心。
在這裡多提一句,
就是目前其實業內對
核心數據空間的理解是有一些
不清晰的,
那其實我們
每次我們說到核心數據空間,
它其實是包含了兩個概念,
一個是生態概念的
核心數據空間,
他們其實雖然說中文名字上
都叫核心數據空間,
但是細心一點的
朋友們可能發現,
中文的翻譯上是不同的,
一個是trusted,
一個是trustworthy,
一個是生態角度的
數據空間,
而另外一個是技術角度的
核心數據空間,就類似於
我們IDS,
其實
IDS
它是一個技術方案,
而歐盟的數據戰略,
它提出要構建
到構建九個
醫療,
低碳,
汽車等行業的數據空間,
它本質上也是一個生態的概念,
所以說數據空間其實是有兩個不同的概念,
而
trustworthy的data space
也就是我們國家數據局
發布的可行數據空間發展
創新發展行動計劃,
裡面要提到了建立100個
可行數據空間,
這個可行數據空間它實際上是一個生態的概念,
它強調的是信任可行的結果,
並不關心,
並不關注於實現的途徑,
它要求你這個
可行數據空間生態要具備
可行管控,
資源交互,還有價值工創
散彈能力,
但是你具體用什麼樣的方式
去實現這散彈能力,
它其實不會對你做出過多的限制,
甚至於說你可以
多懂技術線的融合來去實現它,
而trustworthy的data space
它更強調於
實現可行的過程,
就是你是怎麼樣
通過技術來去實現
我們所謂的可行,
那對可行的定義其實就是
符合預期,
也就是這個定義也是
從國際標準組織ISO上面
漸漸過來的,
就是指
我們數據流通的相關相與方
它的行為是符合預期的,
那這個預期就通過
數字合約來去定義這個預期是什麼,
然後通過使用控制
來去保障這個預期能夠去
實現
這個小的技術角度的
這個小可行技術的關鍵,
它其實是實現
可行管控能力的關鍵技術
數量網,
它從系統形態上是被體現
為三套分布式系統和兩個
胡操作標準,
分布式系統分別是
數字對象巡指系統,數字對象解鎖系統,
還有數字對象調度系統,
來去實現
全球化的數據標識,
通過全球化的數據標識,
實現私語數據的廣域地位,
定位,通過場景化的
資源調度來去私語數據的廣域交付,
通過分布式的數據解鎖,
實現私語數據的廣域發信,
通過標準化的網路間口,
接口來去實現私語數據的廣域服用,
在十四五期間
我們
在數字對象架構的技術上
進行的擴展,提出了
數字對象互聯網技術體系
同時也掌握了
數字對象架構兩大
核心標準之一,
DIP標準的中國話語學員
我們也是在
二十四年十一月的時候
邀請到了羅伯特卡恩
來
我們的數聯網高峰團團做一個
OpenTalk
我們形成了一系列的開源
軟件為技術的
核心技術,
接下來匯報第三部分
我們數據空間全部重點實驗室
在
數據空間和數聯網領域的一些
實驗與展望
首先
我們從
大的數據空間的角度
來去給數聯網產品
產品型態的定位
數聯網實際上
實現核心數據空間
當中
資源交互的一個關鍵技術
它能夠以完全分布
是完全自製的方式
來去實現私語數據的
廣域互聯互通和互操作
基於
這個核心的技術
我們
形成了兩個不同的
一體積產品
包括數聯網輸牛一體積
和數聯網接入一體積
接入一體積
比較輕量
它能夠把數據
它是
可以認為是數據技術設施的
接入一體積的一種
它能夠把數據
相關的資源
給輕量化的接到數聯網上
原來
形成一個物理分散
但是邏輯上互聯的一個
數據互聯的網絡
而數牛一體積呢
就是連接不同的
數據的權亡
發現群職和訪問
同樣
我們也形成了
一個生態化的解決方案
就是
通過場景驅動的數聯網
加上可行數據空間
加智能體的這樣的一個
可行數據空間一體化解決方案
我們把它叫做Zeta
在這個裡面
我們
我們北大數聯網
只做
這一部分
通過
結合其他
生態廠商的整理
來去構建
接入人間系
安全體系
分駁式帳本
還有這個可行數據空間
服務平台
其他來去實現
一網 三權 兩通
網絡化數據流通
可以進一步的
通應用和通進管
接下來介紹兩個
我們典型的案例
第一個是我們在
國家重點研發計劃裡面
做的面向
國家科學數據中心的
技術軟件戰機系統
這個系統它其實
我們國家
只有20個國家科學數據中心
它裡面有
超過3600萬個高質量的
我們每次在做
一個科學實驗的時候
它都需要去
調度到不同中心的數據資源
但是這些數據體量太大
基本上
物理傳輸的效率非常低
所以我們就通過數據網絡的方式
邏輯上把它連結起來
然後通過
向你的算法調度來去
實現分布式的數據分析
目前科學數據網網
已經成功產生
而且生機成為了
技術科學行業科學數據中心軟件戰
建成了由國家兵團
封堵沙漠
對地觀測
氣象 空間 農業等
六家國家科學數據中心
構成了融合科學數據網絡
該網絡有兩個特點
第一 去中心化
Cornet是取中心化聯邦網絡
可實現各個數據中心
節點自製
數據和算法都被抽象為數據對象
各中心由各中心自行管理
數據中心可自動發現網絡
動態聯網
第二 一張圖
通過網絡建設
可形成面向國家科學數據中心群的
一張資源圖
包括數據中心 計算存儲資源
數據及列表
全數登記 算法列表
任務及運行監控
對於科學數據中心
管理員可以查看
各個數據中心資源情況
算法 資源情況
可登入節點 進行數據的發布
審核 管理等操作
對於科研人員
可以在Cornet上找數據
找算法 編排任務
實現跨域協作
在找數據方面
科學家可以通過
予異方式檢索相關數據集一
如請給出黃河流域
於地霸位置相關數據集一
系統會給出相關數據
可以查看詳情 申請使用
可以在網絡上
檢索算法 查看代碼
申請使用
在協作任務編排方面
有了數據和算法 系統提供
所見及所得拖拽配置的
方式實現跨域任務編排
以黃河流域於地霸位置
提取場景為例
該流程需要融合對地觀測
冰川動圖等數據中心的
TB級數據和算法進行
協同分析 遵循移動計算
不移動數據原則
將大任務分解成紫任務
下推到數據所在接點執行
避免大規模數據遷移
實現跨域協作
傳統方式科研人員
只能依據歷史經驗
逐個站點手動檢索
離線下載數據
效率低下且無法保證
數據的完備性
嚴重制約了數據價值的
挖掘與利用
上述過程中數據
算法和協作過程會
以數據與用的方式
還實現了任務編排智能體
基於科學數據網絡中的數據
算法和歷史的協作過程
可以實現面向
跨域任務的編排智能體
支持人在回路的調整
提升協作分析效率
第二個項目呢
也是一個國家重點研發項目
新型研發機構
創新服務平台技術研發與應用
這個項目呢
它本質上解決200個科研機構
20多萬個科研人員
20多個科研項目
還有1000多億的科研經費
它怎麼去研發
成本管控和效率的問題
這個裏面我們繼續
學研網幹了一件
所有科研人員都希望
幹的事情就是論文復興
因為我們知道就是科研工作
其實很大的程度上是
在前期需要去復興
大量其他學者所做的論文
那我們
通過學研網
在archive還有一些
github還有
paperworks code等一些網站上
幫助科研人員把
這些網站上的一些論文
和他們相關的算法
還有數據集
都建立
打算了標識風浪程度數的對象
同時也建立起來了
他們之間的實驗關係
一共有
180多萬片輪文
80多萬個數據集
有十幾萬個算法
建立起來他們的關係
然後同時我們可以
給予這個數據算法
關係
然後通過導客鏡像的方式
來去製作他們的附線
這樣的話其他的科研人員
他就可以直接在這個網絡上
找到他所需要
他想看到的那篇論文的
相關數據和代碼
並且可以實現一件的附線
同時我們也支持
安需替換
你可以同樣的算法
用不同的數據來去對他進行
調適實現不同的效果
第三個工作是我們
支撐
國家藥監局信心中心
做的一個
第三個國家重點研發計畫項目
就是面向藥品現代化監管的
智能化服務平台
研發與應用
在這個裏面
它核心是
國家有700多個藥物研發企業
它有3000多個
清藥需要在1000多個
具備臨床實驗之治當中的
醫院去進行臨床實驗
那這裏面就設計到
藥品研發數據
患者就醫數據
還有一些
患者的用藥數據
它們之間的一個
流通和交互
由於藥數據它極度敏感
基本上不可能通過
建一個平台的方式
來去把數據都給匯聚過來
所以同樣在這個方案裏面
我們就通過數據網
來去構建起來了
用過一個邏輯化的分布式的方式
構建起來了數據和數據之間的
訊息網絡
在這個網絡上
我們可以比較方便的去
知道哪個患者
什麼時候服用了什麼新藥
它的
服藥後的各種
生化指標是什麼樣子的
同時也能夠去
利用這些
按需的去調度這些
相關的數據來去幫助
要完成新藥的
數據驅動的新藥研製
同時因為這個網絡
我們把它構建出來了
所以每年
每次這個國家藥研局
想要對
新藥的臨床實驗
它在上市之前都需要經過
藥研局的評審
還要去驗證你這個新藥的實驗
新藥採集的數據是否合規
傳統的情況下
它基本上只能是
把藥洗幹過的
數據採集的事再幹一遍
來去保證藥洗
所提供的數據是真實的
但是通過數量網
我們構建起來
我們給每一個數據都打上了一個唯一的標識
並且通過
標識建立起來了數據和數據之間的關係
也就是在這裡面
其實就是臨床實驗的數據關係
藥研局
它可以通過這個網絡
基本上可以
非常高效的就知道
這個數據是否真實
把他們的評審效率提升了幾個數量級
同時
基於這個項目的核心技術
我們也在
支撐另外一個
行業可信數據公認識點
招聘行業可信數據公認識點
最後給大家介紹一下
我們當前正在做的一些
工作的進展
就是課創數量網
我們通過前面三個國家重點研發計劃
實際上
通過數量網介入了大量的
高質量的科學數據
科學數據及論文
還有一些先進的算法
甚至於先進的一些
科研團隊的相關信息
我們在基於這些數據呢
其實是可以去深度的
去負能產業界的創新的
很多其實在產業界上
我們遇到了一些科技的問題
它都其實
不多或少在學術界
都已經有相關的解決方案
我們也就是聯合
長江鳥國家世界創意中心
來去共同打造的這個
科創訓練網還有科創智能體
去深度的
負能科技創新和產業創新的
深度融合
這個案例呢我們也是在
國家數據
我們也是在
今年的數博會上
在國家數據紀錄設施的展台
部署了一個可交互的實際系統
接下來可以看一下
視頻演示
在這個案例裡面我們通過
數量網把我們之前建設的
數量網和數據空間的
一些數據級
進一步的串演得起來
就包括科學數據級
算法 論文
還有一些數據項目
甚至於說人際團隊
都以數量網的形式分佈式的
把他們連接得起來
然後呢企業有什麼
產業化相關的問題
他就可以直接在科創訓練網上提問
科創訓練網會分佈式的
去各個地方去搜
把他們跟這個問題相關的
一些數據級 代碼
還有算法
還有甚至於說人際團隊
並且按照傳統一般的
科創邏輯告訴你
第一步應該這麼做
可以用這樣的數據級
這樣的算法嘗試
第二步 聯繫可以進一步的
去聯繫相關的團隊
等等一些類的邏輯
可以看一下視頻展示
科創數連網和科創聚能體
目前科創數連網
已覆蓋十一家國家科學
數據中心
七百六十三家高等院校
和科研機構
二點一萬一家科技型企業
接入了超五十萬數據級
十八萬數據項目
兩萬科創人才等各類
科創資源
通過大模型聚能體
研高校的完成數據資源
應用場景
人才團隊的場景化匹配
與智能化綽合
將規模化數據供給
流通及利用的建設和運營成本
降低一到兩個數量級
為推動我國科技創新
與產業創新
從進息化提成的二點零階段
演進為智能化融合的
三點零階段
啟動了自主可控
實用適用的中國方案
最後基於我們已有的事件
進行對未來的發展
技術一些我自己的看法
首先我們認為
未來大模型和智能體
將是數據要數
價值釋放的主要工具
也是主戰場
而數量網加可行數據空間
將是構造適應
大模型和智能體
這種數據要數
的生產關係
一個重要的技術手段
也就是數據技術設施的
符合性技術
數量網加
可行數據空間加智能體
也會深度的取付
能源工智能加
實現我們產業
從信息化的二點零
向智能化的三點零階段
以上就是我的分享
謝謝大家